- In your mind, why is the
Supreme Court important?
- Well the Supreme Court is important
for the original
founders' reasons or that,
it was like all American institutions
there were ideas the founders had
and then John Marshall,
an important justice,
created the office by the
practice of the office
and it is important
because the court is where
America's thorniest
questions go to be resolved.
They haven't been resolved
in the executive branch
and the legislative
branch and so the court
has to take them up and that is where
the court goes back to
those first principles.
Again, why we study American history.
What exactly was the
outline for how the country
is supposed to behave and are
we staying within that outline
and those series of ideals?
It goes back to the very
beginning ingredients
of America.
So, the court is a test always
of whether what we're doing
now is in keeping with
what we were supposed to do
at the founding of the country.
The reason it has become
so important recently
is that the court ends up
doing a lot more than it was
ever supposed to do because of weakness
in the executive branch
and the legislative branch
and so a lot of people are
now looking to the court
to solve problems that
should actually be handled
by the people's representatives.
The judges are not elected.
They are in there for
life at the Supreme Court
through the process of
the president with advice
and consent by the Senate
but they are not elected
and this was supposed to
be a republic in which
the elected representatives
were the ones making the laws.
But we've shifted away from that
and so the court is now making decisions
that can affect people's
lives and a generation
and not be changed as easily
as say a piece of legislation
which can be vetoed, amended,
superseded by another piece
of legislation.
It's really permanent
changes in the American life.
- So my understanding is
that the Supreme Court
should be above politics.
To what degree is that actually the case?
- Well the Supreme Court had lots of...
There have been times
where the Supreme Court
when Andrew Jackson was president
he tried to use the Supreme
Court to do what he wanted
it to do and Franklin Delano Roosevelt
tried to change the
functioning of the court
because it kept knocking
down all the things
he wanted to do.
We've had moments where
there have been these spasms
where presidents have
tried to get the court
to do what they wanted.
But in general, it was
the American tradition
that the justices were
supposed to be picked
if they were of good character
and if they were of sound legal mind.
If they had views on the manners related
to the Constitution that
were sort of sound legally.
But their politics weren't
supposed to be so important.
What has happened is like so
much in modern American life
is there has been an
intertwining of politics
and the legal profession
so that now when presidents
run for office they say,
elect me so that I can put
in our kinds of judges.
Which means that the
kind of judge you pick
helps you with your
voters and if your voters
want a very specific kind
of ideological judge,
then the more ideological
the judge that you pick,
the greater your voters
will be happy about you
and that'll keep you in office.
And that is true of the
senators advising and consenting
on these decisions and
true of the presidents
who pick them.
Well that means that the
people who go into the office
into the Supreme Court I should say
end up being more
political than in the past.
There was a period where
when an American president
would pick a justice,
that justice very often
would rule in a way that was
totally the opposite of what the members
of that president's party wanted.
It happened repeatedly in American life
and that was a symbol people thought
of the idea that these
issues before the court
were being weighed on their merits
and had nothing to do
with the ideological views
of the judge weighing them.
Now, where you sit on a particular issue
is often determined by where
you came from politically.